all right hi hey how are you you guys
are both very good-looking but I'm
really fascinated about about you
because you are scary
oh we shook it we can realize in real
life you're adorable but on the show I'm
like I have nightmares it's pretty
gnarly no these are my prosthetics on my
face right now yeah what was that
transformation like for you it was a
profound transformation I would say you
know the character I play ranges in age
from from close to what I have now all
the way through a hundred and
thirty-five years old there's five
phases of physical transformation that
that I underwent for the process and and
it was it was exciting it was sometimes
challenging to go through you know I
think the longest version was about four
hours of hair makeup but but we worked
with the most incredible special effects
makeup artist Joel Harlow Ritchie Alonzo
and Cheryl Daniels and the three of them
are just so incredibly talented and
generous and they made the whole process
really enjoyable so and they gave me
they gave me a place to go right like I
could really immerse myself in who this
character is physically and transform
and know that the choices that I was
making as an actor we're still
translating to the story which was the
most important part of it for me any
side effects to that transformation now
that it the filming is over only my hair
to shave my head with like a actual
razor every night before I'd show up for
work so it's now going back and it can't
grow back faster like taking care of
vitamins I'm just trying to get it to
come back but I missed my hair I've
never had to do that before like shave
for months at a time and it's definitely
I liked it I mean yeah it was cool for
like the first week it's cold and
where's my hair with bangs oh but Cheryl
made it look oh my goodness so you have
an Australian accent yes and you're
playing an American teenager and
anything fun you had to learn to play
that role I had to Adia
the word placate the other day because
you guys say play capes return it do you
guys say placate yeah yeah we this is
different you know was an interesting
actually it was an interesting journey
because originally we were thinking I
was gonna go for the Massachusetts
accent and then we departed from that
idea because she was kind of within
transitioning between worlds anyway and
wanted to escape that environment so I
went to fairly standardized American but
with like a little bit of a mess mmm
touch except the Massachusetts accent
has some Australian sounds in it so it's
confusing and I didn't want people to
think that I just couldn't do an
American accent because I mean this is
amazing American accent and when we
first met you were actually only
speaking and now from sometimes
accidentally so talking it yeah it would
be like sometimes she would talk in her
American dialect and sometimes she was
talking restrained I liked so I'm an
American coach Amanda Glade amazing that
would be great like in the club meeting
a guy and using a different accent right
like different names for identity
when I waited tables I used to I used to
do different accents stop you know I did
probably not well but I remember what
I've pretended I was French and was on
the bosses but and there was a French
guy next to me and I pretended I
couldn't really speak English and he was
like ooh too powerful say and I was like
[Laughter]
wait why that one so so the show is very
dark what made you guys want to be a
part of it you know interestingly I had
some resistance to it at first you know
because it's sort of in the wheelhouse
of other stuff I've done over the years
and and I thought I don't know if I
really want to go back into that kind of
villainous you know dark horror rooted
world but then I read the script then I
had conversations with Jamie O'Brien our
showrunner and kharece calluna director
the first two if it doesn't show and I
felt like there was a lot of complexity
and emotional depth to who these
characters are and there was this
incredible collaborative spirit around
the project and ultimately that drew me
in combined with the opportunity to
really transform into a different
character and then I read the novel
which I felt so compelled by so there
was just a lot happening and I felt like
all the people that were coming on board
were really on the same page and that
doesn't always happen you know they're
almost all the episodes were written
before we started shooting was an
incredible experience to be able to know
where our characters were going and
anticipate their journeys so I didn't
know
oh you didn't know I only had been as as
we went alone but in because I think I
was Carrie and Jamie wanted me to kind
of stay present with the journey let it
develop yeah and your character I think
has your journeys a little more volatile
whereas my character's journeys a little
more consistent so I found it helpful to
kind of know where he was going so that
I could kind of inform choices that I
was making in its in other episodes and
I know everyone is excited about the
Goldfinch movie
what can you tell us about that what is
it coming out I don't know the official
answer that I think my dad told me that
it comes October 11 well if your dad
knows yeah that's probably the most
reliable yeah so hopefully then because
they've booked flights - yeah and then
in the show is I'm imagining that your
characters are going to collide at what
point are we gonna get this yeah what
point we don't know answers that might
be the spoiler yeah the seasons really
build I think one of the cool things
about the show is actually that it takes
this time to really explore Vic's
relationship with her parents and her
peers and her own life choices at the
same time it's exploring bankses journey
- Bing Partridge and the kids and like
and part of the tension of the first
season is you know building to the
showdown the the collision between these
two worlds so it definitely happens
right kind of coming in and out of each
other's orbits and then there's there's
a one in particular moment that we the
use of the word showdown just got me
very excited about this okay thanks so
much
you